oh my lance okay nobody's taking it good
skill level beginner whatever
and we are off what a game wanna give me
three okay
so a3 is a pretty common
and i'll make a move just so the game
isn't important a3
is a pretty common move among beginners
and i'll explain sort of why i think
that is
afterwards now as you guys know it's not
a great move and we usually respond with
e4 now
the funny thing is it's it's not a
terrible movie they're basically we have
e4
e5 with colors reversed and a3 thrown in
which is not a bad and let me just
enable arrows here which is not a
terrible
move by any stretch it's actually
helpful it stops me from
playing the rye lopez we should play as
if we were playing one e4 right
so knight f6 and we should just develop
our pieces just like we normally would
right now we can't play the right lopez
of black we can't put our bishop on
okay bishop a6 is sort of you know he's
he's just moving his pieces now
obviously which way should we take this
bishop should we take it with the pawn
or with the knight
should we take it with the pawn or with
the knight
yeah we should take it with the knight
now there's no point in taking the pawn
and ruining our whoops
that was the mouse slip i'm also taking
the pun
now the reason now the funny thing is uh
we can make the most
out of taking with the pawn we can make
the most out of taking of the pawn
so one of the fundamental tenets of
of this level is that you should care
much less about pawn
structure than you do about peace
placement right
so we can repurpose this and fianchetto
our bishop because we have a little hole
on b7 right
100 bits thank you and i gotta re i
gotta disenable the alerts
from the start so by fianchettoing the
bishop the enchanting means to put the
bishop on the long diagonal
okay so he goes knight b5 he's giving up
his knight to the pawn now we're up two
pieces
and okay so he goes b4 now at this level
obviously i'm not gonna beat around the
bush here a lot of the
you know art is just to take stuff
that's hanging and
we got to be very careful about what we
take now this is still hanging what do
we take it with should we take it with
the bishop or with the knight
yeah so we should take it with a knight
um just
to keep the knight centralized uh we
could take it with the bishop also
it's not essential it's not that
important uh but to remind you of one of
the key themes
when you're up a lot of material you
gotta not forget to develop the rest of
your pieces
okay so he goes eight four he's he's
sort of he's playing on the flank
and he's obviously a beginner you know
let's not i'm not gonna pretend that
you know he's moving his pieces he's
he's unsure
of of what to do now a4
right it creates technically speaking a
point of tension on b5
but that's like we're you know we're a
huge bull
a snowflake has landed on our
like toe and to react to this is like
picking up that snowflake and stopping
the hunt that you're currently on
uh so instead of reacting to this let's
focus on what's important here which is
to develop our pieces
and what pieces haven't we developed yet
well we haven't developed the bishop we
haven't developed tonight
where do we want to put this bishop
where do we ideally where do we want to
put this
ideally if we could put it anywhere what
would be the ideal square for it
well it would be c5 right if we could
put it on c5 then it would combine with
the knight
to attack f2 but we can put it on c5 we
just have to take this pawn first
and then we can just return to c5
okay so bishop a3 we can't return to c5
instead
he offers us a trade but in these kinds
of situations don't automatically
simplify
look around the board see if you can
find anything better is there anything
better
all right well we have a knight here we
have a bishop here they're combining
they're attacking d2
we can play bishop takes t2 check and if
he takes then we play knight takes d2
yeah so again with black i'm playing so
i'm playing more solidly so we're
you know sometimes i'll be holding
myself back
yeah we'll get up to a reasonable level
pretty quickly so like if you're
14 15 hundred you're like this is yawn
you know
the first couple of games can be kind of
dull for you
but uh i prom you know we will get up to
a good level pretty quickly okay so king
e2
in these kinds of situations there's a
couple of things you look for you look
for mating patterns obviously
you also look for ways to exploit the
vulnerable king that aren't checkmate
one of them is forks
we have a knight on e4 we have a king on
e2 this is like fork central so we can
knight c3
and we win the queen and we're gonna win
the game
um yeah knight takes d1 okay so another
thing now i know we're up like 150
pieces but actually this
is when you're up 150 pieces
that's actually one of the best places
to practice good habits
and it i know it sounds weird but the
reason that is
is because there's no consequences to
messing up really you're going to win
the game anyway
so instead of just fooling around and
making some dumb moves and
you know trolling your opponent it's
actually a very good idea to
focus on being super precise
now he's not taking any of our pieces
back
so when you're up this many pieces and
you're trying to mate the opponent as
quickly as possible
one of the things that you can do is you
can sacrifice back the pieces very
strategically we're up
a queen and two pieces we can sacrifice
a minor piece back
in order to shatter the defenses around
his king how can we do that
now i know this is like absurd anything
wins here like it literally doesn't
matter
but if we were to do this properly i
would play knight takes f2 some of you
are suggesting 93 track i'm doing the
same thing except i'm like taking a pawn
right
okay he's not moving he's taking the
rook here and this is just uh
and now we're we've paved the way for
queen after we've just done it by taking
the rook
yeah i think that i mean obviously this
guy's a total beginner
yes we have six straight we can take the
knight here we can also just go
go up to f2 um
but you know but by no means if
people who are watching the speed run
are beginners
this is not meant to disparage players
who are just starting to play
by any means i understand how it can
look that way
but please be assured that that's not my
intention i
just it is what it is um okay
so well queen takes d4 i'm not really
commenting these moves because
obviously it's pretty straightforward at
this point
there should be four coming in with
another check we could also take the
rook
i'm probably not finding the quickest
mate it doesn't matter this one really
doesn't matter you just gotta bring your
pieces in and give checks and it's going
to be mate
queen c3 check is another check
and then queen takes c4 and queen c2 is
made so
okay so i i realize some people think
well i should start at a thousand
but i there will be total beginners
watching um
watching on youtube and i'm pretty sure
maybe some of you are six seven hundred
so uh i think it's worth playing these
couple of games it's it's not gonna be
more than six seven games like this
right
okay so could you try to find the
fastest made in situations like this i
think it would be helpful to see how you
do it
yeah i mean it's more than i i don't do
it any differently than you guys do
and one resource that i could recommend
if you're having trouble with basic
mates laszlo polgar
the father of the polgar sisters he
issued a
huge anthology of mating puzzles
i think it's it literally is called i
think five thousand three hundred thirty
four mating
mating problems or mating puzzles it's
you can get it you can download it
online
it's an amazing resource it is mates in
one two and three in
great numbers if you if you're serious
about training you can sit down
to 10 15 of those a day for two months
and you're going to greatly improve your
mate-related pattern recognition so this
move like queen c2 how did you see that
so fast i didn't even see it it just
occurred to me because i've seen the
pattern of the bishop queen battery so
many times
um okay so
we won't spend too long on on these
games obviously um
because i you know they're pretty
straightforward
he plays a3 um e5 and
e4 and those of you guys who
started chess recently you will know
that beginners tend to push their corner
pawns i never
actually knew for sure why that is the
case one of my hypotheses is that
maybe when people just start they
they're afraid to play in the center
because they're afraid to expose their
king
and you also want to get your rook out
there's something about getting your
rook out early that
that appeals to people because it's sort
of one of the more powerful pieces
um so here a3 5e4 is good and
of course bishop a6 white is you know
just not not playing well here now the
move is knight c3
and then we would play as if it were an
italian we could just play bishop c5 and
d6 and
when i say as if it were an italian what
i mean is that by with colors reversed
we have an italian with
a3 thrown in and italian is e4 e5 knight
f3 knight c6 bishop c4 so if you compare
this position
to this position i know it looks really
weird
but it literally isn't italian with
colors reverse kind of trippy i have a
story about
that i've shared the story already so
the story concerns grandmaster rutmir
holmoff
wait did i already share that on stream
i think i shared that on stream but
let me share it again wrap your hole off
was a soviet grandmaster
a very strong player actual real person
very strong player
multiple times contended for the soviet
championship he played nickel towel
he was really good uh but he was a fan
of
you know imbibing during tournaments as
were many soviet jams
and during one such tournaments he had a
long night
uh before with tall and other people
tall left early or so the story goes
omaf stayed and you know he had a long
night and the following morning there
was a round
homo was black um against
some you know international master and
um the master plays d4 home off plays
the dutch defense and
tall is standing there watching home i
was like that's why
it plays f5 knight c3 okay that's in
that standard move
and uh coleman plays e6 which is pretty
rare
and then f takes c4 and then knight c6
and then tall into his horror watches
and play h6
and tall comes up to what are you
remember what are you doing
i'm playing the night earth and then of
course this is like the night or
uh mirror reflected to the other side of
the board
which is not very good so anyways um
that was the colors reversed mirror
image story that i had
at the night or of course is is e4 c5
knight f3 d6 the same moves on the other
side of the board knight f6
and then a6 instead of h6 uh so that's
i don't know how true of a story that is
i heard that from my old coach
i don't know how the game ended anyways
um
bishop a6 so the reason i would take
with the knight is not to ruin the pawn
structure
i've mentioned that it's not
particularly essential to keep your pawn
structure intact but that doesn't mean
you have to
deliberately try to ruin it either um
and bishop b7 we're making the most of
it we're fianchettoing the bishop the
fiance of the bishop means to put it
on one of these four squares that's
literally the definition
um and what you know when if you're new
to chess you hear these words thrown
around it can be very intimidating if
you get away
yeah how'd you do frank go i think
getting my bishop to be opening up feat
of both of my bishops
um but that's all all that it means and
the reason fiancados can be good is
because
this is mathematically speaking the
longest diagonal in the chessboard
numerically
and when you put a bishop there the
bishop controls maximizes its utility by
controlling the most number of squares
now to peace placement is a function of
two things right how many squares it
controls
and the sort of specific role that it
fulfills if you think about a graph
so a piece can be incredibly powerful
and control very few squares
or it can be you know very very
bad and control many squares but those
are relatively rare cases you will find
that generally speaking the more squares
the piece controls the more active it is
the more
well-placed it is the more
well-functioning it is but obviously
if that were a one-to-one correlation
then positional chess would be as easy
as one two three and it's not
so i'll be talking more about peace
placement as we go along thank you
that's gifting to noah okay so the rest
was very straightforward we're just
taking all of the free pieces
uh if anybody has any specific questions
about
you know what i did here feel free to
ask them otherwise
um you know i'm just gonna slowly go
through the game but there's really not
much to explain we're just
knight takes f2 is really the only move
where we're really doing something
uh we're destroying the protection
around his king side giving up one of
our minor pieces
um so knight take taking the rook
getting the queen involved taking his
knight
getting the bishop involved and then
delivering the checkmate at the end
um okay uh why do you only take into
account one diagonal when considering
the strength the bishop placement
well you can know you take into account
both you take into account both
i think you mean both diagonals the
bishop controls just that this diagonal
is not very
long um how to get rid of fiancato
bishops
so one of the downsides of fianchettoing
in general right
is that you and let's let's consider a
the simplest fan kettle which is like
the modern defense
the problem with pushing the pawn out to
g6 is that you create a hole on h6
that's the fundamental issue
and on f6 potentially with the fiend
keto creates holes so
if the fiance bishop is uprooted then
what remains are these dark square
weaknesses where the bishop used to be
so there's a trade-off to fianchettoing
also it takes longer than just
developing it normally
why not queen f6 instead of knight f2 um
well yeah you can play queen f6 but then
he takes the knight and you haven't
succeeded in
using the knight effectively why is king
f2 better than queen h4 at the end there
i mean queen h4 is also good but the
same reason you can take the night with
the zero
um and i think that that how do you take
advantage of the dark squares around the
fiance of bishop so that's where the
lobster pincer may come since if you
watch ikaro
you'll hear him say lobster pizza mate
or you'll hear me say that
and a lobster insurmate generally occurs
when a fiance bishop
is uprooted or traded so for let me give
you a very simple example that doesn't
isn't from a real game or anything so
what can happen is this is called a
battery a battery is a
um you know it can be a queen bishop
battery queen rook battery
um but it generally refers to a queen
and queen and a bishop that are stacked
up in a diagonal
and in this position white can play the
move bishop h6 which essentially forces
the trade of the fiance because you
can't drop the bishop back well you can
but you lose in exchange
exchange is a rook for a bishop and if
you take
then white takes on uh h6 and
what can end up happening is a situation
like this
right and i've played horrible moves
with black that's not the point point is
what i'm trying to demonstrate here this
is the lobster pincer mate
it's like pincer's claws that are
clamping down
on the g7 square queen g7 mate is
inevitable
why is this even a thing well it's a
thing because you played g6 in order to
function of the bishop
so obviously
lobster instrument do not only occur in
the event of
incredibly cooperative play from the
opponent um
i can show you plenty of games where
they occurred in grand master games
so um but but that is one of the sort of
negative externalities from from fiance
right
i don't want to talk too philosophically
here we'll have plenty of opportunities
guys
to discuss fiances and stuff like don't
worry about
uh like oh this is the only time we
discuss this yeah so the proper play
would be to leave the bishop there the
proper play would not be to help white
activate his queen and get it into the
attack normally
here the proper play would be just to
develop the knight for example
[Music]
you